we Define maturity as as leaving home
and of course that's very problematic
for the Millennials because many of them
are still living at home and many of
them know that they're not going to have
a home well I'll be more careful they're
not going to have a house they know that
my son is going through that right now
he's living with me he knows and he's
like he's working full-time high school
biology teacher that would used to be
the kind of job that you could build
home and family around and he's still
living with his dad and that's hard on
him this this is part of it there's a
sort of a double whammy on these on
these kids because first of all they're
not allowed to be homesick because of
the cultural thing but then they can't
fulfill the cultural thing because the
culture is basically giving them the
finger when they try to do it and the
Philippines are saying oh no no no no
you want to leave home
not for you right and I'm worried that
there's already a powder keg of
resentment and then these machines are
going to disenfranchise I mean
economically even more people and the
resentment is going to become
like murderous yeah
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is Paul and as you can see from
the other four people on the screen we
are going to talk today about the
conference coming up in May the Quest
for a spiritual home that's coming up in
May 18 to 21 in Chino California Chino
California is about 40 miles east of Los
Angeles Chino California has its own
airport the Ontario Airport in
California and so he can fly directly
there tickets are available and there's
a link below but when we were talking
about setting up this conference as men
as you can see Catherine is involved in
this and Catherine set up the Thunder
Bay conference we very much wanted this
to be in continuity and to continue the
conversations that we began in Thunder
Bay and we had an offline meeting where
we agreed on the topic the Quest for a
spiritual home and so so I thought in as
we move towards this conference
um I think I thought it would be helpful
to sort of continue the conversation
online which will sort of give us a
little bit of a bridge to then getting
to the conference so some people noted
that at the Thunder Bay conference the
the title of that conference was
Consciousness and conscience and some
people noted that we talked a lot more
about Consciousness than we talked about
conscience and so some people have
suggested this will probably have a sort
of fill out the card that we left
unfinished in Thunder Bay
um so those of you who might not know
who all is in this circle Jonathan pajot
um is obviously here John vervaki as
well Catherine was our moderator in
Thunder Bay and she will also moderate
at in Chino and John vindonk who has
worked with me a lot with the Estuary
program is is located in Chino and it's
his it's his church that is giving us
the facility to host the conference and
John is setting this up and I thought uh
John would be an important voice because
in a lot of ways a lot of John's whole
life story has been a quest for a
spiritual home and and I would you know
don't want to speak for John but John
and I've spoken about this a lot that in
in a lot of ways John is still sort of a
a Restless Wanderer in his quest for a
spiritual home taking some time on the
Camino pilgrimage in Europe and he'll
he'll share a bunch of different things
as things progress I thought maybe we
would begin with Jonathan and John
because I think both of them have been
doing a lot of work that I think is is
very much in continuity with the idea of
a quest for a spiritual home John of
course has his after Socrates series
which has been coming out on his channel
Jonathan as been involved in The Exodus
series on daily wire with Jordan
Peterson the kinds of conversations he
usually does and also a lot of travel so
maybe a way to get into this John and
Jonathan would be for you two to sort of
give us a little update on what you've
been doing and how that begins to prompt
your thoughts on this idea of a quest
for a spiritual home and what we'll be
talking about in Chino
either of you can go first
I can go first uh
and so I mean
I think that the idea of searching for a
spiritual home is something which is
it's a it's endemic to the situation of
being a postmodern person of living you
know in the suburbs of growing up
deracinated I myself there are some
advantages in some ways to being kind of
a Wanderer I grew up
in several cities my parents moved a lot
when I was young my I know I lived in
the Canada and the US and
um and then I lived in Africa as an
adult and so in some ways I am an
outsider just generally there's an
advantage to that because you can also
be a translator when you're an outsider
you can kind of and Paul you you've
noticed that in the what I'm doing is
that in some ways I talk about the
symbolic world but I'm always bridging
between the two I keep moving between
the world of the kind of scientific
material this world that I criticize but
I moved from that and I try to point
people into a more embodied experience
but it means that I also have the same
issue that everybody has right I have
the same issue that most that I even I
criticize about the modern world which
is you know I have
the difficulty of being a feeling fully
part of something and to be you know
kind of fully integrated into uh
into a spiritual home and so you know
becoming Orthodox for example was in
some ways part of searching for that but
in order to become Orthodox you almost
also have to deracinate yourself and you
you also have to be able to be willing
to experience the strange and to and to
kind of be able to
you know tame a new world and and and
and reintegrate a world that isn't
obvious and isn't easy and so the one
thing I can say about finding a
spiritual home is that as contemporary
people we have to be deliberate about it
we can't
it doesn't just happen you know like
some maybe some
16th Century Village where you go to
church you have the parish you've got
your the priest there who's been there
forever and you everybody goes to
confession and everybody participates
and you know what the celebrations are
and you know and Christmas we have this
local tradition or whatever all these
things are pretty much gone for us and
so we have to be deliberate about it
and so for for me in some ways it's
difficult and it's and it's very it's
hard not to still have alienation but it
also makes whatever connection that I
have
very precious and I you know I I I I
grab onto it and I and I feel uh like
it's transformative and so I went to
mount Athos as some of you know in the
past few weeks and uh you know that was
a mix of those two things where I'm in
Mount Athos everybody you know I'm in
church with people who are singing in
Greek for three hours and in some ways
you just feel this weird surreal
experience of not knowing what's going
on and not kind of knowing uh but at the
same time I I was able to feel connected
to to the Orthodox tradition in ways
that I'd never experienced before and so
I come back very much re-enlive and did
my own practice in my own prayer life in
my own faith so yeah so I don't know
where I'm going but I would say that's
where I am that's what you asked where
are you so that's kind of where I am in
that in that uh respect
so um I am
reflecting a lot on
the Quest for a spiritual home of all of
three of the key elements Quest spirit
and home
so around home I'm doing something that
might catch you totally by surprise I'm
doing the cognitive science of home uh
what goes on there what is this sense of
belongingness what's why is it how does
it link up to issues of orientation
navigation
um and so
um I'm thinking about that and making
use of also looking at some indigenous
cultures
um who feel at home in the world without
having housing
and that may help to bridge to what
Jonathan was talking about what is it
like to be definitely they definitely
have home
they definitely have home without house
um and that's very interesting because
we seem to have the reverse we seem to
have houses with our homes
and by comparing and contrasting that
can we bring out
what it is home is doing for us
um and there's there's
um you know I'm sort of building towards
a proposal that and this is built on
something Jonathan said at the
conference about he was talking about
like um meals and how they sort of level
up
I'm trying to take how does
how do we exact up and that's part of
perhaps the spirituality how do we exact
up
what you might call physical home
um into spiritual home and what does
this what's it what's spiritual about
that spiritual home
um
and this has sort of two things uh one
is a broader I've been making a broader
argument I did it
at uh
when I was at Ralston and I've done it
really I've released that talk just
yesterday uh the talk I gave at the
conciliency conference about leveling up
and about how the possibility
of a deep or a strong kind of
transcendence which is not just
psychological Improvement but the psyche
is transcending and aspect levels of
reality are being reliably disclosed
um and uh arguing for that
um
and
I'm trying to mesh that understanding
uh and again influenced by Jonathan the
idea of Faith as this sense of being
able to level up if I could put it that
way
um and so I'm working on that
and then what has been really consuming
me for the last two weeks I'm preparing
a video essay for the end of the week at
which this recording is happening on the
scientific the philosophical and the
spiritual significance of the GPT
machines and what do they mean for us oh
my goodness about all those and what and
how that might intersect with our sense
of being at home cosmically because I
one of my things I'm going to argue for
I'm not going to argue for it right now
I think there's a deep connection though
between Cosmic at home fitness and
spiritual being spiritually at home and
part of the quest is how to weave those
together and how to exact
um
physical home into that so that's sort
of where I'm at and what I'm wrestling
with and it's uh
um
and I I got to spend uh eight hours
yesterday walking and talking first with
just Jordan Hall and then with Jordan
Hall and Christopher Master Pietro
around to this and I've been working on
this as a specifically uh what does what
does it mean for us now that these
machines are emerging and uh and trying
to cut through uh there's a lot of
on both sides about these
machines that have to be cut through
very carefully and then uh we're gonna
face I think some reliable decision
points and I think those decision points
are really going to be bound to the
normativity of home
do we want to do we want to
still have a home in the universe
um there's a question we we really I
know that sounds like bizarre that we
should even ask that question uh but we
I'm gonna argue it uh let me get to
Chino we are facing that question so the
quest is very much a quest it's not just
the questioning question you know the
questing and the questioning it's also
the facing facing peril and really
important ways
um and so that's where I'm at right now
okay
John Catherine you guys want to throw
anything in there
well I I have given a little bit of
thought to what I might bring to the
table
um as a participant in this conversation
um I I I'm somewhat self-conscious in
part because Paul keeps referring to me
as the old man I'm somewhat conscious of
my age and I I would like to think of
myself as representing the Boomers and
perhaps make some attempt to redeem the
Boomers
um but uh the the other thing
um
that that my life experience has
pointed out is that there is no such
thing as a linear trajectory
um
in the Long View there's a lot of ups
and downs and two steps forward and one
step backward and three steps forward
and two steps backwards and and so
there's that feature
um
yes I have some experience with
um a quest in the sense that
um I actually walked the Camino de
Santiago which is a traditional uh
pilgrimage which was originally thought
of in the olden days as a as a very much
a a quest to achieve a spiritual end and
uh and and and reach a spiritual
destination but it was also clear that
um for the Camino at least the the focus
was as much on your daily place to sleep
as it was the final destination so uh
there is a there is a sense in which
some of our focus on the Quest for a
spiritual home cannot be the final
destination but all the stops in between
and so that's one thing that I would
like to focus on a little bit
um I would also like to contribute um
in some fashion
um I don't and I don't really know where
or how these things will all come up in
in our conversation but uh the fact that
I've had a bit of a aha moment kind of a
time in my life when something became
particularly clear and um and I'm kind
of intrigued by what Jonathan said
earlier about how how
um this stuff doesn't happen
automatically you have to almost
position yourself even for an aha moment
for a particular Revelation so I have a
couple of stories that pertain to that
um I would like to have the opportunity
along the way to perhaps say something
um on a more procedural uh knowledge
kind of line about how Estuary works and
that's of course something that I have
been busy with for for
um
for several years now together with Paul
to try and and figure out how to make
that happen on the ground and what are
the mechanics that actually make that
come alive and make it work so there is
some procedural things that I would like
to
um bring to the table
um there are some things that I would
like to say about my relationship to my
rather conservative Church
and how it becomes in some fashion an
anchor
for my mental meanderings my myopic
mental Meandering and that it provides
me with a sort of a reference point from
which to judge whether I'm still in
touch with reality and and what does it
take and how did that church you know
obtain the right in my life to to be
that anchor and and that is actually a
story all by itself
and uh so yeah that's probably some of
the stuff that I've been thinking about
some of which may be meaningful in our
conversation if it doesn't all come up
that'll be fine as well
okay
Catherine
I have a few thoughts
um I think at the Forefront of my mind
I just think about
um the feedback we got from the first
conference
and how helpful people found it
I was talking to somebody about a month
ago who watched through the series
online
and she said that um
the the word that described it most for
her was luxurious
she found it to be emotionally and
spiritually luxurious to just listen
without feeling like behind every point
there was this pressure to go out and
now there's the 10 things you have to do
like here's a thought and now go forth
and change the world and be a new person
but there was just room to really talk
and really unpack and really
work through and see people processing
in real time
so I think at the front of my concern is
the hope that we can continue that
pattern to continue the
um
really privilege of being able to take
time to really unpack things
thoughtfully and do it together
so that's my first thought is I hope
that that pattern can continue
um my second thought is in line with
what you were saying at first Paul that
my thought in the initial conference was
it would be nice to see how each of you
consider Consciousness differently and
then to see how that might lay itself
out in a moral ethical pattern so since
this is what Consciousness is therefore
what would your conscience lead you to
what should the ethical implications of
that be and I think that lines up really
nicely with this theme of a quest for a
spiritual home because that's all very
active it's all very much instantiated
how do we do this how do we live this
and
um again it might not land with like
here's the 10 things to go do but is
there a sense that we can get of the
pattern of how that might feel talking
about rituals and rhythms and how do we
go about this in a way like John said
that's a process it's not just where we
land at the end of the trail but the
stops along the way
um that's the second thought um and the
last thing I've been thinking is
since this theme came up I've mostly
been looking at it from the one side you
know this idea that
we want a spiritual home like a a
structure in which we can rest
spiritually
but there's a flip side to that too
which means that if you have a spiritual
home you're going to be instantiating a
spirit within it
and so I think a good question is what
kind of spirit do you want to be
patterning within the home that you're
creating because it's this double-sided
thing where you will create space
um for your spirit and other people's
spirits to rest
but you also are then going to be
um
participating in some internal pattern
and so being conscious of what Eternal
pattern it is that we want to be
instantiating I think that's the flip
side of the conversation that I I hope
we get around to at some point as well
maybe picking up on where Catherine left
off
um
thinking about what happened at Thunder
Bay now John wasn't there but the other
four of us were
what what for you are you hoping for
from this conference either in
continuity with or perhaps a pivot from
there will be playing ball for Jesus
there will be paintball for Jesus yes
and it won't be raining
I I really enjoyed the conference so
much and you know because there is
something and we talk about home or talk
about the sense of of uh
of connection you know and I think that
being in the same place together it was
definitely a great added value to
to for the conversations to have a
different flavor to them and so I really
definitely enjoyed that so I think that
I'm looking forward to a continuity of
that you know and I think in some ways
the the theme is perfect already like
just the things that that uh John rivaki
said I've got like it's just buzzing you
know I wish the conference was tomorrow
so we could talk about all those things
because it's just like there's there's
so much comfort there's so much uh
there's so many things to tap into and
to think about
um so um so yeah by the way I'm I'm
speaking to Jordan Hall as well about
this question soon and we're going to do
it more from the principality angle of
it and you know the question of of
agency over us also this kind of these
these patterns that act on us so so it
all kind of ties in but I think that you
know the
um I think that being in the same place
will be very fruitful to to to
continuing these discussions
anyone else
I mean I want to Echo what Jonathan said
I'm hoping for a continuity of the uh
like the spirit of that previous
conference so that was just I I think
luxurious is very apt that's how I
experienced it
um and um
and uh I felt you know we all got to
places we couldn't get to individually
and for me that's the Criterion of
success uh and I
um I'm expecting I think I'm reasonably
expecting that's going to happen again
so I'm looking forward to that
um
I I I'm hoping that
this topic does a little bit more of
bridging to people who are not
religiously oriented
I mean we we made this isn't the
criticism of the previous conference
because it was a it was a learning
experience right
by making sure that was one of the
reasons we chose this title in fact we
chose it collectively all of us we work
together too it was a product of
distributed cognition you might say
um but um
something that would Bridge uh very
deeply between people
who are religiously oriented and those
who aren't religiously oriented uh
because I do think
um
that question is now
we being able to cross that divide so
that we can meaningfully and deeply work
together I think is now even more
pertinent than it was four weeks ago
and so I think making sure that we
properly tend to that bridge
um I think is something I would like to
see given a priority at this conference
I I also think
one of the things that I very much
appreciated about the conference was
again to be in person I even though or
many of you watching this the primary
mode of connection you have with
especially three of us is our images on
flat screens and our voices coming out
of speakers and you might in fact be
listening to us in your home you might
be listening to us in your car but the
the opportunity
the opportunity to knit something else
together
and and for me
as as we we think about how we will
spend the time over Friday Thursday
Friday Saturday and Sunday in Chino
to me a priority is to
make a space so that more knitting
together can be done not let's say oh
you get a chance to do a selfie with one
of the speakers but you get a chance to
uh you get a chance to make at least I
like John vindonk mentioning the Camino
you get at at least a chance to have a
manse to to locate for a brief overnight
with a group of new people and find out
what that means in terms of the bonds
and bridges and connections and growth
that can happen in there one of the one
of the aspects to this is that Grim
Grizz tells me there are still 15 spaces
available at the campground so those who
would like to camp for this and truth be
told I'm not going to Camp because I'm
speaking and it's a little hard to prep
for a speech if you're if you're kind of
up to your up to your neck and other
people camping but part of me is you
know really wishes I were camping
because I know from from growing up
church campouts and and camping with
friends that that living together in in
a way that we often only do when we camp
outside is something that facilitates
and prompts
um the kinds of connections that will
will I think facilitate
the Quest for a spiritual home and even
though
of course
you know you get to watch myself or
Jonathan or John on YouTube
it's the it's actually there's always
churn with these these these sort of
false relationships with screens you
listen to Jonathan for a while and
you'll listen to Paul I'm listening to
John and then you're over here this
other channels and and the this is an
opportunity to build some other
relationships that are can actually go
deeper and in my experience it's those
friendships friendship relationships
which actually
transform us more than you know oh I
listened to Paul Vander clay for three
years on YouTube
you know that's it it's the face-to-face
belly to belly nose to nose stuff and
this is an opportunity for that and then
the the overall speeches you know both
what Jonathan said and what John said
already and what John and Catherine have
already said you know that sort of
teases me but I think that sort of opens
up sort of the micro Fishers in our in
our settledness to allow new growth and
transformation to take place so and I
think we had a beginning of that in
Thunder Bay and I think we'll have
opportunity for more of that in in Chino
um
I I've sort of directed this so far me
asking questions but I don't want to
leave it in that manner I don't know if
any of you have questions or challenges
or or something you want to throw out to
to prompt this
I just
told to throw out the fact that
the way the three of you have in the
past few years uh engage in conversation
with one another
models a certain style and a certain
openness and a certain towardliness that
that's very admirable and and very
enjoyable and it has that sense of
lingering that Catherine was talking
about
uh but we would like that model to
translate into an underground experience
also which means that it would be pretty
much ideal if it could be orchestrated
that a goodly number of people that
normally hang out at John's Channel or
at Jonathan's channel would would also
be represented
um at the conference so that there can
be a little bit of a mixing of these
three demographics which I'm sure are a
little bit different from one another
and and kind of uh symbolically uh
represent you know in which the three of
you symbolically represent how three
different ways of looking at the world
in three different ways of talking about
things can actually be practiced on the
ground in Chino that would be my super
goal and and uh I would be just
delighted if if that could be realized
which means that I would very much like
uh John your people and Jonathan your
people to also come to Chino in the in
similar numbers to uh what what what is
coming from uh from Paul's Channel
so uh I agree that's great what should I
be doing I mean I'm going to promote
this video on my channel and promote the
conference that maybe I will take that
maybe I'll take okay
yeah I didn't want to do it earlier
because it I mean generally I found you
don't want to be that far from the event
or people just don't do much about it
they put that they just they they I'll
mentally file to do that and then
nothing happens and they don't do it but
I think we're close enough now I'm
really happy to like promote this on all
my platforms and promote and mention
airline tickets
airline tickets we're gonna get more
expensive if you wait longer oh yeah
that's true I'm actually I I was
supposed to get mine yesterday but I was
with Jordan so I'm gonna Taylor and I
are trying to coordinate so we can fly
in together Taylor Barrett and I
um so he was also at Thunder Bay
um so yeah I'll yeah I'll scare people
too then yeah but for sure that you know
John to your point uh van Duke Van Dunk
sorry that to your point in terms of
having all these people come together I
for sure at the uh Thunder Bay
conference it was amazing to see the
variety of people that had come you know
uh and it was it was very interesting
and then also to notice people in the
group you know create bonds with each
other and discuss all across all kinds
of of interesting lines and so I think
we'll definitely see more of that in
this in this conference and then I have
a question from Catherine Catherine when
you saw the tickets being purchased was
there a pattern among the people who
paid for the tickets that there were
just a lot of women who paid for the
ticket or was there or were there
actually a lot of women who showed up at
the conference I find a pattern right
now is that I I'm I I see the name of
the person who buys the ticket and a lot
of them are female names so either we're
going to have a whole bunch of uh women
and girls at this conference or else
they're buying tickets for their loved
ones and it's going to be a bunch of
guys that are going to show up you want
to speak to that Catherine what do you
think is going to happen
sure
um I found that there were quite a few
couples that came and so often the wife
would were a girlfriend or partner would
go in and you know
um sign up and it would all be in her
name
um and there were quite a few Single
Ladies as well there were quite a few
women at the conference and I was
pleasantly surprised because I tend to
think of our Corner as being a little
more nerdy and a little more oriented
it's that more cognitive thinky-talkie
space and not as much of the Hands-On
um but there were quite a few women at
the conference and I'm really hoping a
lot of them will come to this one as
well because I really enjoyed meeting so
many of them we had a few women sign up
for paintball for Jesus so be prepared
guys we we didn't have any women at in
paintball and Thunder Bay so oh really
so I did I didn't remember if they were
women or not yeah so interesting
well it is it is interesting to me how
um
how yeah YouTube is a very male oriented
space but and I've noticed with our
Estuary meetings too and here in
Sacramento more and more women have been
coming and it's it's interesting to me
how it's always interesting to me how
they sort of reshape the conversation
and the Dynamics in the room
and so and I did notice that at Thunder
Bay that there were good what percentage
were women at Thunder Bay did you do run
any math Catherine I didn't but off the
top of my head I would have said maybe
30 yeah yeah
I think that's a you know especially
given the
I really like what I mean this this home
thing John really sparked with Awakening
from the meaning crisis when he talked
about domicide
and and John also this time when you
talked about
um you talked about those who aren't in
those who are not currently see language
is harder those are not sort of
currently residing in a particular
religious house let's say and I you know
I know people look at me and say well
he's a minister so he's doing this one
thing but you know as a as a minister I
most of the people I actually work with
are sort of religiously homeless and as
you often mentioned John those those
numbers of the nuns that's been one of
the one of the very interesting
demographic realities
and and so this you know part of what I
think we've seen with the ongoing
rise in globalization
um affluence transportation is that many
people
they are placeless I don't know I don't
know any of us in this you know Jonathan
mentioned he grew up in how many
different places I don't know how how
many places you've lived John I've lived
I'm an immigrant I'm an immigrant for
starters yeah the Donk is an immigrant
Catherine
um she's got a very interesting story in
terms of growing up all over the place
with a religious family
so I think you know especially seeing
women in this context women are you know
women are often home makers in many ways
men tend to be distracted foraging doers
and women are often centering and so I'm
I'm really happy to see this the
beginning of what I think is probably
more of a demographic balancing I think
probably a maturing of this conversation
and community
all right hope so I know for sure that a
lot of the people that come in kind of
meeting crisis types that come into the
churches they end up being guys and then
you just have these crazy lopsided
churches with like like in my prayer
says what's going on you know it's all
these like wave of like 20 guys you know
like coming in and then
just a few ladies
so hopefully that balance out in general
will balance out in terms of you know
people kind of kind of entering into
these conversations
well maybe this brings up uh I don't
know if it is and not maybe I'll be able
to connect it but um I'm also interested
in um
I'm interested in the the other side of
this I'm interested in homesickness
and how is that related to
what's going on I have the book uh not I
have not yet started reading it about uh
at the beginning of the first half of
the 20th century homesickness was
considered a major thing because of the
rate of immigration into uh North
America
seriously and then there was a sort of
cultural shift in which
um being sort of economically nomadic
became uh recommended and then
homesickness was looked on as a kind of
weakness
and
what book is this John uh if you'll uh
pardon me for a sec I'll go get it sure
that's
you know I I lived part of another
interesting little facet of this corner
the first conversation I had with
Jonathan we dug into you know your
journey in Africa and you talked about
the fact that I didn't know you lived in
the states for a while
um yeah my father studied he was a he
studied at Denver Colorado at a Baptist
Seminary there I forget what it's called
and then he I lived in Wheaton my dad
was uh Wheaton grad school
when when
oh that's the title of the book yeah
homesickness Susan what's who's the
author Susan big Matt an American
history
um
so this is not uh this is not an
analysis like of the phenomenon uh like
a like under unpacking its cognition or
or it's phenomenology or anything like
that it's an attempt though to
understand
um why we shifted culturally from
recognizing homesickness as a
significant and real thing that people
had to be helped with
to no no no if you're homesick you're
just immature you haven't grown up you
failed to launch and my part of my my uh
this is only a weak hypothesis but part
of
my thinking is this is a contributary
factor to the meeting crisis that we
right
um is that people are in some sense
experiencing domicide homesickness but
they're not allowed to articulate it
that way and so they're thrashing around
in other ways of trying to articulate it
um and so
um
you know and of course this goes back to
ancient themes of you know Augustine you
know we're Restless until we uh find a
home in God kind of thing
but I'm particularly interested in the
clash between these two normativities
that seem to be both spoken about in our
culture as if they go really happily
together
um when of course they don't
um
home and right and and family values
that are nebulously useless phrase
um uh because you know the Manson family
had family values um so uh I I don't
know what that yeah it's it's dependent
family and the type of values uh but uh
there's that but then we we push a
culture
um that emphasizes right uh like I said
economic being an economic and those two
are like and you know etterstat has made
a very good argument in How the West
really lost God is that it's the rise of
individual people living alone is the
most the thing that is most powerfully
correlated with loss in belief in God uh
take that for what you want I'm not
making a theological claim it's just a
straight demographic argument that when
people lose extended deep homes they
lose a sense of why a sense for God I'm
trying to speak as neutrally as I can
here yeah right and so I'm trying to
also wrestle with how like we should we
should recognize that these things are
actually in a profound tension and they
have a lot to do with people's uh
spirituality
um and you know that you know this
overlaps with the number of close
friends people's has is reliably
declining also Each decade
um and
um so there's there's something here
about
um
I think a vacillating unstable framing
of Home in our culture that is also a
significant contributor to a lot of the
other things we're talking about
yeah but it's interesting because when
you say home and especially you
presented it home in some ways as part
of the orientation mechanism yes and so
you know and so what happens in it even
without realizing you know you have this
value hierarchy which says something
like you go to college and then wherever
you can get a job right that's where you
go you just move there and then you make
a life there it's just a normal it's
like a normal thing you leave your home
you go to college you maybe you find
your spouse there and then you find a
job and then you go to that place and so
that this is just a normal way of
functioning uh shows you part of the
Orient the orienting mechanism itself
right what it is that that's making us
make decisions uh and then the let's say
the the downwind from that is it is a
general destructuring of these
intermediate not just family but just
intermediary uh
structures of cohesion like you know
your clubs your boy scouts or whatever
all these things yeah the fellowship
hold this together yeah because the
economic the economic Vector becomes the
only thing that really matters you're
making money accumulating things
yeah and those things buffer us right
and they're the technical part the
technical aspect of the thing that we
have it's the they're all kind of
extensions of each other right
industrialization these computers these
machines these things they kind of
buffer us from each other and then they
also become our orientating our
orienting mechanism themselves
and the uh the
the preachers is um and I'm not really
totally speaking as a preacher but
certainly as a person from a church
perspective is that if you find yourself
in a church that seems like a good fit
a place where you feel comfortable a
place where things are said the way you
think they should be said
and where the programs and the projects
pretty much line up with your priorities
and perspectives
then there is a good possibility that
you may be in the wrong place
in that sense yeah in the sense of of a
kind of complacent because a home is not
it's it's it actually it's difficult
right it's like being in connection with
your parents your family your siblings
that have been grading you for your
whole life that there's been these
little things accumulating it's a
difficult thing it's not easy where
these online communities are easier
because it's all people you know it's
like I like being with John rivecky you
know it I I chose him as a friend he's
not he's not just someone around me
that's getting on my nerves because they
live in the neighborhood you know it's
it's a different type of of reality
well this goes to a point that I want to
bring up I'll bring it up in my talk but
also foreshadow it a bit here I think we
shouldn't be talking about home and
isolation I I want to argue that there's
a home Horizon access axes instead and
that um that is what we're trying to and
we even got it a bit with the quest
Motif in there uh if if home is
orientation in stenberger another not
stenberger uh that's that's the I've got
the wrong name the guy who wrote the
orientation book I'll remember it uh but
if that uh you know if home is your
original not just temporal but like in
origin Like An Origin point on a map
right if if home is your original uh
your origin for orientation it's but it
it right it also has to be in
relationship to Horizon
uh in in an important way
um and it's interesting that home has
this I mean this was part of what Ryan
Walsh was arguing way back when when I
met him on the train and read his
article right that uh poem is also a
place where we're we're it's a symbolic
machine for world view Attunement and it
is designed to orient us
um uh to uh to the Horizon in some
fashion
um and so not that John the thing that
you just said fits very well with the
idea of the pilgrimage where there is a
destination exactly there's a
destination and there is these different
places where you can spend the night but
the thing that is most reassuring on the
Camino
is those little yellow conch shells that
tell you that you're still on the right
path
and and and and they they they are
noticeable from the beginning to the end
and they give you an orientation of kind
of where you're going but they most
definitely are not a place where you can
spend the night because they're just a
little tiny little marker thing they're
just a little marker but but they are
they are as a whole they are the most
reassuring thing on the Camino
well that's exactly it like so I'm
interested in the in cultures that do
not have houses and yet uh like uh some
of the Australian indigenous cultures
like they they you know when they have
the dream lines and and such
um and so they they found a way of of
not
being bound to this or that but
nevertheless they have a way of
orienting towards the horizon because
they're all they're they're moving
around a lot and um I think that
that's there's something to be learned
from them I don't know what it is yet
I'm still working on that but there's
there's definitely in the I think in
most religious Traditions there's a
weird tension between uh a kind of home
and self alienation to a certain extent
like asceticism can be understood as a
type of conscious alienation and and I
think Jordan Peterson really captures it
in the ways he talks about it you know
it's like on the one hand you need
enough home to give you that anchoring
orientate orienting mechanism you don't
want too much because then you just you
know you just kind of run around in
circles and you you become too
comfortable uh and so you see aesthetic
practice and pilgrimage is a good
example seems and you see that in in a
lot of the monastic especially the early
monastic uh authors where you know they
went to the desert you know they they
went out and put themselves in
horrendous difficult lonely situation
because they were they they could see
the Horizon they knew that they all also
has had to de-anchor themselves in order
to move towards the horizon and so I'm
not saying that's what we should do in
some ways now we have too much of that
like we have too much de-anchoring and
we don't have the the the the stable
orienting mechanism but it seems for
sure there always has to be a discussion
between those two those two sides well
I'd like to bring that up too at the
conference because I want to talk about
the two Grace the two well I consider
them the two great home myths of the
West one is Odysseus and the return to
home and one is Abraham and the going to
a new home and and you know the Greek
and the Hebrew orientations there and
what does that mean because that's part
of what I mean by the the home Horizon
polarity you're it's it's it's it's like
this is Abraham going away from home to
a new and this is Odysseus trying to get
back right and we have these two great
and so that's what I mean about I think
when we're talking about home we're
actually talking about a polarity
between
like something where we are grounding
and then somewhere where like this is
assimilation and this is accommodation
or something like that yeah yeah and I
think that plays out in the you know
that our Notions of the Sacred also have
that polarity in it we talk about the
sacred is that which makes us most at
home but then there's the numinous right
that is also deeply horizontal I don't
want to say horizontal because that word
doesn't mean what I want it to mean but
horizontal right right in a really
really powerful way
um and so I mean this is a this is a way
of saying that I think
sacredness and the home Horizon polarity
are also deeply
um interpenetrating with each other in
important ways
um and that's why we have these these
and it's interesting that the West has
these two myths and it's holding on to
both of them uh in a profound in a
really profound way yeah well think
about think about the the craziest image
is obvious I mean to me at least
craziest images what's happening now
like for me we're entering Holy Week in
the Orthodox tradition and so we have
this image of the Cross which is
obviously the most alienated possible
it's like everybody hates you your
people the everybody everybody's
betrayed you everybody hates you and
then Christ is on the cross with this
thief and he says you know today you
will be with me in Paradise
foreign
that's home right Paradise is the home
of homes it's the place it's the cosmic
home you could say the best way of
saying it but then he says that in a
moment where basically everything that
he can imagine is falling apart so it's
like the the Paradox is captured in a
crazy way in in that story well I want
to pick up on that too I mean
because Jesus in a couple of the gospels
says he doesn't have a home yeah doesn't
have a home
um and so just have holes and birds have
nests but the son of man has no place to
lay his head yeah yeah and he uses son
of man you know that's not insignificant
to that quote yes yes I was yeah I'm
gonna pick up on that but it's it's so
it and and and the Buddha says very
similar things
um
um and so again
I'm already doing what I want to do I
want to problematize this as much as we
possibly can and then wrestle with it
because yeah I think it is a deeply
deeply problematic thing uh but I think
it's also a deeply deeply human and
deeply deeply needed thing
um
and like I said I'm worried that we're
about to face something that is going to
be as if you took the invention of
alphabetic literacy the printing pulse
and the Telegraph and release them all
at the same time they won't make the
same impact that these machines these
new machines are going to make on us
yeah um and you know and that the
printing press is you know the
Protestant Reformation of religious wars
it like wow it's going to be bigger
um so I like I I I wanna like I want to
really wrestle with this really really
deeply like take it to its steps and
crack it open as much as you can
will people leave the conference in a
panic yeah
no no that's not what I want I want
people to leave the conference with a
profound sense of discernment that will
allow them to address this that's what I
most want people uh to have I mean and I
don't think that answer is going to come
from me I think it's going to come from
all of us and all of the people who come
just like that's what came out of like
that's what came out of Thunder Bay
right it wasn't any one of us
um I'm really hoping that
I I I I I'm sort of placing my faith in
that our the spirit will be able to
engender there will give us some
disclosure about how to orient ourselves
right now
we don't know I don't know right like
what is happening I mean I have my kids
they're young so they're more they just
it they they're they're seeping into
them really fast because I got a huge
had GPT to be honest I tried it for like
15 minutes got bored with it but my kids
they unders they can see like what this
is and they intuitively just
go straight to it and uh and so and then
every conversation now every other
conversation I have is is someone
telling me about that in church in
anywhere I go it's that's what
everybody's is is talking about and so I
think John you're right like this is
what there's an explosion happening
before our very eyes and it's funny that
I didn't I didn't link it to I was I was
thinking more about the problem of
you know the problem of of the
relationship between technology and
intelligence and and how humans fit in
that but I didn't realize or I didn't
think about the question of home and how
in some ways it can blow us out of the
okay just blow up our our parameters for
what we consider to be and even like
what our place is you know because I
didn't because that's what it is
ultimately it's like what's our place
think about the irony the enlightenment
was which was Promethean and said no no
human beings are all where history is
all about in the tea loss and now the
enlightenment has betrayed us because it
might put us in the hands of non-humans
um in a powerful way
the one thing that sort of tutored us
about how to live with beings Beyond us
religion has been undermined by the
modern history so we're sort of like oh
um right maybe we aren't ultimate and um
oh no uh what do we have as a resource
for dealing with that question well
stuff we've been taught for four
centuries to not really believe it and
I'm not advocating a return to religion
because I think this is going to have an
impact on religion like the printing
press had on religion
religions are not going to be Untouched
by this they're going to be profound
challenged and I would argue even
transformed by this but nevertheless we
like this is in some sense
I I hope I'm not misunderstood I hope
people will also wait before they jump
on this until they've seen my video
essay but I think this is ultimately a
religious question these machines yeah
oh yeah really profound way it's about
what is our place in the cosmos and is
it the place we have believed it to be
for quite for several centuries right
um
I really appreciate your um you're
talking about it as a as a wrestling and
an attempt to discern these different
Dynamics and uh it's gonna be fall on in
some degree on Catherine I think to um
find we're going to have to together
find some kind of a balance between the
individual presentations that will be
um forthcoming from each of you and then
some conversations that will take place
amongst yourselves but uh Paul and I
have already talked about how we
definitely would like to make room for
people in their own
small groups and conversation groups uh
to to be able to wrestle with these
questions on the ground themselves
amongst themselves and to kind of see a
pattern emerging that they can do that
um henceforth in other words that this
is not a one-of kind of thing where you
know we're going to go to Chino and
we're going to try and solve all the
world problems but rather that um we you
know we we not only have a sense of what
are the issues but we also have a sense
of how can we process the issues along
the way down the road so that's going to
be part of the goal I think for this
conference and we have to make sure we
leave enough time for that to take place
I think we have to give that a priority
I mean I think
we have to I mean I would hope that one
of the things that comes out of the
conference is people have a
um a guiding sense of what it is to
exemplify being being able to feel at
home in the world in a way that is not
fantasy or uh spiritual bypassing or all
the other temptations that are going to
arise for people right now
so yes very much uh like don't tell me
what you believe tell me what you
practice it's got to get into where
people will see
realize for themselves
in these groups like what can they
practice that will be like the best
possible way of responding to this
Kairos I I am I have no doubt that we're
now in a Kairos this is a Kairos
um just absolutely pivotal
um what it could be it's not crazy to
say this could be the biggest turn in
history
um and so we are here now and we have to
try and uh
we have to try and help people as much
as we responsibly and best can thank you
very much John I totally agree I don't
want this to just be talking about it
that's it's a time for just talking
about these things is passing
hmm
Catherine you wave your hand if you want
to get words in edgewise and I will I
will make sure I make special words to
sneak in
um
John I really liked what you were saying
about the need to complicate things
first before we try to
answer the questions and so two of two
things were coming to mind as you guys
were talking one was
um
so the image of sort of
Odysseus and Abraham these two versions
of spiritual quests
something that struck me is
now you guys can correct me but it seems
to me that those appear to be more
masculine versions of this course
but the feminine version of the quest is
how do you maintain the home which is a
different type of quest
even though you still stay in the same
plot spot
usually although not always
um if you leave it's usually the
feminine role to reinstantiate the home
to rebuild the home but often the story
is there's a home to come back to and
usually it's
some feminine element maintaining that
space
well you know this yes that's clearly
the case Penelope is she is a wise
trickster you know holding off all these
these suitors and and kind of actually
making and unmaking the home right she's
weaving and unweaving and she's kind of
leaving the the home in the kind of flux
in order to prevent a new seed like a
new identity uh of taking over it's a
pretty astounding imagery that's used in
in
Ulysses
who did you say John I said Sarah also
has a rather unique story in Abraham's
homecoming perhaps not exactly as
admirable as Penelope but it's a story
just well Sarah and Rebecca are both
under threat
that's true because you know it's
interesting that Abraham sojourns he's
got to go into Egypt and so in a sense
Abraham commits domicide when he says oh
that's my sister in order to in order
and I think there is a lot of domicide
that happens out of fear of
self-preservation and you know one of
the things as you guys were talking too
there's a lot of class element in this I
often reflect so I have a cousin who is
just a few a few months different than
myself he his family was Blue Collar my
family was you know my father's a
preacher we moved around he stayed put
he's a welder so he works with his hands
I'm a pastor I work with my words and my
mouth and and I look at the shape of Our
Lives in Your Hands and my hands I've
I've lived in he's lived in the same
town his whole life
and
um you know that's that's a piece of
this this too that
um you know people uh John I really John
viveki I really like that that that
homesick idea because you know it seems
like 30 40 years ago people would brag
oh I'm a citizen of the world in a in a
way saying I'm I'm rootless I I get
married on a pretty beach someplace I I
dine with uh High status people over in
this area and there's almost a a
flagrant celebration of rootlessness
and um so I don't know Catherine if if
you wanted to continue with with your
point
well I actually want to jump off what
you're saying because that was that
leads into my second Point
um when John was talking about
um the homesickness the book that came
to my mind was Andrew Sullivan's book
far from the tree I don't know if you
guys have read it it's a it's a fat one
um but essentially it's a number of
interviews where he talks with people
um he was a gay man he grew up in a
conservative home felt very much like he
was the fruit that fell far from the
tree and so it's a number of stories
with people who are far from the tree so
he interviews
um criminals from families that aren't
criminal Geniuses
um
people with particular disabilities
particular abilities anything that
exceptionalizes them and separated them
from their home
but what made that come to mind was
because it's such a I feel like that is
become
more the ideal now it so in the past you
had the homesickness you you missed calm
you wanted to be there but now it seems
like
most of modern culture
people are encouraged to Define
themselves in opposition to their home
and so being far from the tree isn't
experienced as a a hardship although it
may actually existentially be
experienced that way but we don't
culturally Define it that way we
culturally Define that as your true
identity which is understood and
opposition and I wonder how much
um that dynamic if we could explore that
in
and engage with that might answer some
of this
uh domicide that we have because I I
just see that as sort of the inverse of
the book that you're reading John
yeah I was very thank you for saying
that I think you said it uh better than
I did I'm very interested in that that
yeah we've got this
we got this you know we got the loss of
homesickness as a positive and it's now
become a negative as you said and we in
fact we we Define maturity as people as
as leaving home
in an important way I I think that was
very well said
um and of course that's very problematic
for uh the Millennials because many of
them are still living at home
and many of them know that they're not
going to have a home well I'll be more
careful they're not going to have a
house
they know they're not going to have a
house they know that my son is going
through that right now he's living with
me and he knows and he's like he's
working full-time high school biology
teacher that would used to be the kind
of job that you could build uh home and
family around
he's still living with his dad
and that's hard on him I mean
um I try to not be here as much as
possible so he can feel like it's his
place I'm sorry I was very helpful for
that uh but um but like
this this is part of it right
um we we like so there's a double
there's a sort of a double whammy on
these on these kids because first of all
they're not allowed to be homesick
because of the cultural thing but then
they can't fulfill the cultural thing
because the culture is basically giving
them the finger when they try to do it
and the Philippines are saying oh no no
no no you want to leave home
not for you not for you right and and so
yeah I mean I think I'm worried I'm
worried that there's already a powder
keg of resentment
and then these machines
are going to disenfranchise I mean
economically even more people and the
resentment is going to become
like murderous yeah
it's interesting you know we talk about
transformation and and in
in oh let's say wisdom oriented you know
we we want Transformations I I think
John that really gets into your both
because you transform from something but
that really much more gets into the
horizonal aspect too because you want to
transform into
um something that is you want to
transform actually into you've talked a
lot about this in your work John
um you know who who you are to become
there's that that's there's that second
self that you talk about and but but
there is a there is a necessary domicide
that happens in transformation Jordan
Peterson I think talks about that well
too in terms of there's something that
has to break
in order for something to be reformed
and Jonathan your point too about every
Thanksgiving
one of the things that goes through the
culture especially sort of the uh the
Zoomer class culture those of us who are
citizens of the world oh I have to go
back home for Thanksgiving oh I have to
endure my Racist uncle or my
um my pen pecking mother or my
um withholding of approval father and I
mean we have all of these cultural memes
around this
um
very much a an anxiety and and even an
anger in some ways with respect to home
and John John viveki well you just said
and then if you sort of get trapped in
home
now and this just just coming out of
covid where for example I had three of
my adult children you know back into the
house for the beginning of the pandemic
at least and so there's there's a lot
going on in this space
but here's something that I like
again I I I'm trying to not give away
all the secret sauce yeah yeah for the
for the confidence
because I mean there's another myth
there's the odyssian and the abrahamic
and yes Catherine's right we should pay
attention to the feminine side of those
myths so that's a very good point
um but the there's Plato's myth of
animesis that when you get the the most
the most significant anagogue is also an
act of deep remembrance right and and
and that your your your highest
aspirational fulfillment of
transformation should bring you into the
deepest acceptance of your finitude and
mortality right uh and and so I I think
Plato is wrestling with the tension that
we're bumping up against here and he's
saying it doesn't have to be like this
tearing there is a way in which we can
find right there's a way in which we
both and this sounds like a paradox even
to say it we can reach for the Horizon
as we are gathered very very deeply back
into home and that is also something
that I want to propose as something we
need to is that definitely I think it's
great memory is I mean we talked about
memory we talked about that in our last
discussion sorry it's not online yet so
memory seems to be part of that question
like because I think of the story of
Jonah and and the fish you know how God
tells Jonah go go here right so he's
telling him to leave home and go to this
other place uh and he he doesn't want to
and then because of that he finds
himself in death right he goes down but
then when he's in death it's actually
connecting the two together that makes
it work he says I remember God I
remember the holy place I remember the
temple I remember you know the the this
holy place which is his home spiritually
and because of that then he's willing to
to move it's like this idea that if
you're connected in memory then you can
go far because you don't Lose Yourself
completely you you have this anchor and
then you have the the capacity to see
the horizon
and and that reminds me of the
psychological research around secure
attachment right that it's the person
who has actually the the child that is
actually properly
religio to the parent that actually is
capable of exploring and when you're
reading the adult attachment literature
they they they they they they're very
sort of critical of the dependency myth
you shouldn't be dependent on anybody
but they're saying no no no human beings
actually explore most when they are
deeply connected to somebody else that
is original for them in the way I'm
trying to use it and so that is also uh
like that to me is also uh you know
holds open the possibility that we have
within us ways of being ways of becoming
that can address this tension this
problematization that I've also been
pushing on
I feel like I'm giving away too much all
right so but then I have to tell you
that the whole question of home is
pressing on me right now because I it's
it's actually past the time that I
should go back with my family and help
with dinner and do all that stuff the
time got changed last minute and I'm
like wait a minute so so I actually have
to go and leave and leave all of you and
uh and uh and give my last invitation to
everybody who's watching this to uh to
come join us in Chino because I it's
gonna be a lot of it's gonna be a lot of
fun all right go ahead Jonathan I'll
close out after you're gone all right
it's good to see everybody bye-bye all
right bye-bye take care Jonathan bye-bye
hi Jonathan
no I think I think John you're giving us
a
um you're giving us a real you're giving
us some some good hors d'oeuvres in
terms of what we're going to want
because when you start unpacking this
you begin to realize that this
I mean Quest as as we talked about Quest
is it's not just a it's not just a oh
there's a destination here I have to get
there yes
right I'm not exactly sure of the
destination either and but there's a
there's a poll and a push that that are
coming along and we've talked about home
and I think probably as with Thunder Bay
we won't be able to fit all of the words
in one short weekend but you know the
question is all the questions is also
going to be well what on Earth do we
mean by a spiritual home yes because in
this I I really like the language you
gave it John in terms of it being
horizonal because that's going to sort
of leave an empty space for for
understanding spiritual it's not just
emotional although it is that
um but it's orienting and it's active
and it's moving but it's also you know
horizontal I really like that word John
that's that's really helpful
um just want to say that Solomon Andrew
Solomon
s-o-l-o-m-o-n not Sullivan when I heard
you say that before Catherine I looked
it up Andrew Solomon uh far from the
tree
so
any any other I don't want to have too
much conversation without Jonathan here
but I don't also don't want to truncate
anything that needs to be said
I'm I'm not going to say anything more
that would be valuable to other human
beings
[Laughter]
I I uh I feel Jonathan's lack very uh
very significantly yeah yeah so
um any anything else any detail things
so this will come out on our various
different channels ticket links will be
below and I'll share those with all of
you to include with your uh on your
channels as well
um they're still our tickets still
available there still is camp sites
available
um the only crunch is I am not 100 sure
that Jonathan's trip to St Andrews
Orthodox Church
um can accommodate many more people
because
um I I think he's going to be addressing
the group about the icons that are in
the church and I'm not sure that it's
easy to move around with you know more
than 100 people in in that church and
so I'm just thinking about the specific
Logistics I hope to ask them about that
but that if you really want to
participate in that particular feature
on Sunday you better get you better get
your name on the list so that's all I
can say about that all right anything
else anyone
Catherine you're you're okay to travel
to the United States
I think so I don't think it's been
lifted quite yet but I'm sure no no
today today
I'm good to go you signed the thing that
the emergency has been officially lifted
perfect Catherine is about the country
good well thank you all for your time
and um we look forward to get your
tickets below we look forward to seeing
many of you at in Chino California
coming up in May please come everyone
it's going to be it's going to be
amazing foreign
I'm really excited to announce that we
have just put up the new symbolic World
website this new website you know marks
the return of the blog symbolic World
blog the return of the reading list and
also a brand new symbolic World
Community which is accessible and will
be hosted directly on the website this
community can be accessed by anybody who
subscribed to the symbolic world for
those who are who were already
subscribed and supporting us a different
level of patronage either through PayPal
patreon or subscribe star all you need
to do is put in your email address you
will get a reset link for your password
and you are in and for everyone
everybody else it seems like a good time
to join the symbolic world to access all
these new things we're also offering a
few new gifts to everybody who
subscribes even at the level of free
subscriber just to thank everybody for
all the support you have given us all
through all these years and I have to
say it's just beginning we will soon be
announcing new courses uh you know
Richard Roland is preparing a course on
Beowulf there are all these new projects
the new Snow White Project God's dog and
the symbolicworld.com will be the place
to follow this and to get news and you
know some uh a few Peak sneak peeks at
what is coming in the future so thanks
everybody for support and like I said
we're just starting